well the Clippers don't have any
timeouts remaining Sacramento has two
remaining Malik Monk
has been everything for the Sacramento
Kings time now I believe was the shot to
those two overtime and he's gotten it
from the outside he's had multiple dunks
in this game he's getting into the paint
getting to his spots he has been so
fantastic in every aspect of his case
and he's been very solid on the
defensive end and we have to talk about
why the kings are even in this double
overtime game right now because
defensively in the fourth quarter as
we've seen them do multiple times they
turned it up 6.1 to go they put a little
bit of time back on the clock
[Applause]
trigger for the Clippers
Gordon man Powell and Leonard they try
to hit Powell
back out to Batum for three it's off
rebounded the Kings stormy daily and
come up from the tomb to win this
they resurrect their hoax late in the
game
revived
reinvigorated Reborn
Malik monk with 45 points in a historic
win for Sacramento
they get to stop at the end game they
were able to do it on the backs of two
guys Dearing Fox and Malik Monk and they
came up on the defensive end as well the
team as a whole did a great job but you
have to take your hats off to what
dearan Fox was able to do and how Malik
monk stepped up to the plate game high
45 points you have Kawhi Leonard with
44. Darren Foxwoods 42. this is a game
that I will never forget Mark Jones
de'arron Fox
enough to feed the knee the knee tonight
42 points 12 assists five rebounds and a
kiss from his lovely bride to cap off
the night
the final score once again 176 175 in
double overtime that'll do it from LA as
the king shocked the Clippers in double
OT oh I got sweat coming off of me for
Katie Christensen I'm Mark Jones thanks
for watching everyone Kyle and Kenny are
standing by with King's post game live
presented by Tyler which starts right
now like the beam guys
all right
Powell attacks
Westbrook to the rim and lays it in
151 148 timeout Sacramento what they're
doing before they get fouled right away
box going for the two lays it up and
lays it in no timeouts for the Clippers
as coach pointed out
possession coming up for both teams
[Applause]
month for the time
1.1 the play they kick to the opposite
corner look on the right side of your
screen right side of your screen that's
where he is elevating knocking it down
right here is where you can foul if that
was what the philosophy was coming out
of the huddle
[Applause]
monk splits a pair of Defenders and then
floats it in what a tough shot what a
play by my league months 33 for monk in
32 minutes off the bench seven to shoot
for George
Westbrook in the corner for three he put
it in the Tomb with 19 Off the Bench
Fox the floater in and out Neptune
counted in a foul
you watch an explosion on the inside
this shot
in and out rebound goes tomorrow
full steam ahead
oh my goodness respect for monk wow both
hands throwing it down
35 per month and a leaping rebound by
Westbrook Clippers looking to score
first here in overtime Westbrook from
the line to the Lane to the random hand
on the Clippers draw First Love rise up
right there he sees the opening so now
he turns it on goes right through the
white jerseys lays it in both shooting
still at 60 percent
Powell for three in the lead he got it
167.
Powell with 22 Off the Bench
[Applause]
gets a good look at the iron and leaves
it in Malik monk with 42 Off the Bench
looking to break the ties Fox and
overdrive fumbles it and kicks it off
his leg Clippers on a power play
Leonard spins Fades and connects Kawhi
and Leonard with 44.
Westbrook dared to shoot it five on the
clock Plumley to the rack oh he flashes
it in
169. beautiful pass by Westbrook
15-16 footer and how about that block
shot and once again Sacramento has life
month for three I'll tell you what
that's insane 45 for monk off the pit
Plumley pocket picked again and once
again Sacramento with a chance to take
the lead
mental mistakes can't put the ball down
if you don't know where the Defenders
are
[Applause]
Fox knocking down the 17-footer